Good morning.
I am David Ferriero, I'm the Archivist of the United States
and it's a real pleasure to welcome you to my house this morning.
And a special welcome to those who are joining us by webcast.
I know there are a number of library schools participating
and it's a pleasure to welcome you especially the folks in Boston - hello, Simmons!
This is a fitting place for this meeting.
This is a house that holds history
and I believe today we are making history so it's very
appropriate that we're all here together.
I want to knowledge two very special people this morning .
We wouldn't be here if Bob Darnton of Harvard haven't taken this on as a personal cause.
And I have first-hand information from my five years at the NYPL, where Bob is a trustee
and the conversations we had about doing something here in this country.
Bob, thank you very much for getting us started.
[Applause]
Another important person is Doron Weber and all the folks from Sloan
who saw the importance of this and actually put money to where we were going
and made this possible. Thank you very much. [Applause]
We are lucky to have with us graphic reporters,
Martin and Heather are capturing what is happening today which which is wonderful.
The work streams met yesterday at George Washington University
and we want to thank them for making that possible.
Thank you to all the the DPLA team, the Secretariat
and the Steering Committee for making yesterday such a productive day.
I am high on DPLA and you will hear more from me in the next session,
but it's a real special treat to be here this morning.
And a special treat to introduce a new member of the
administration who came back to Washington just before I
did in August 2009, James Leach who is the chair of the Endowment for the Humanities,
Jim served 30 years in Congress and as I reminded him this morning,
we have his records upstairs. [Laughter] Jim Leach.
[Applause] Thank you, David. I want to tell you a story.
We had a meeting a few months back
and someone came up to me
and said some of the nicest things
and I was kind of blushing.
The person looked up and said you are the archivist, aren't you? [Laughter].
I am in David's shadow.
I would like to join this revolutionary throng
in thanking David and the National Archives for hosting this meeting
and make a few observations from NEH's perspective.
NEH is in the knowledge development and dissemination business.
We are concerned with recording of the accumulated knowledge of the past and facilitating research in the future.
We're concerned that the concept of research is being co-opted by science in a time
when humanistic understanding has never been more important.
We're full bore in support of scientific in endeavor,
but we also think it critical to prioritize idea exploration
and access to the wisdom of the ages.
Half a century ago the English physicist and novelist, C.P. Snow gave a controversial lecture called "The Two Cultures"
in which he lamented gulf between scientists and what he called "literary intellectuals".
He cited several six samples.
Scientists are hard to break beckons
and humanist who couldn't to find the second law of thermodynamics.
The Gulf might be described as a literacy matching in numeracy in academia.
Snow held the breakdown of communications between the
sciences and humanities hindered solutions to problems.
What is the situation five decades later? The science
and humanities division is more extreme today as physics
has become math dependent, biology more complex and scientific or theoretical.
From a methodological perspective the technological
revolution began with the digital computer which was
discovered at Iowa State University and allows humanities
and sciences to share an increasing portion, Brown.
Digitization of books enables the application of methods
to vast amounts of social science data. Technology
and the Internet give an open window to humanities.
The social market of our times is the emergence of a new
digital class characterize by his -- then by curiosity.
The important division in the new communications aides is
no longer the one between science and humanities.
It is a -- you have crossed the digital divide
and those who seek information from diverse sources with an open-minded perspective.
The question of whether -- would cause greater understanding
and social integration at the community level
or lead to greater tolerance is yet too be resolved.
What is clear is that few revolutions in history can
match the consequences for learning a big development
spread of digital communications devices
and the software capacities that fueled the use of hardware.
The issue of the quality has been looked upon as a
political ideal type two techniques and organization and governmental policies.
In the modern world access to knowledge -- an opportunity
across the globe and has access to the ballot boxes
and been the key to advancing political rights.
The development of marks and letters represent words, the invention of paper
and the printing press have been sitting stages in human progress.
The concept of establishing in the public domain
and a vast conglomeration of written material
and created matter appears to be an extension of these prior revolutions.
We don't know how such an institution will be managed or how it will progress.
We don't know what to call the enterprise.
We don't know how the cost burden of the effort will be
shared between corporations and nonprofit community and governmental bodies.
We do know that shortly we are going to hear from the
21st century incarnation of James Smithson.
Whatever the cost, if storage is far cheaper
and user-friendly than localized efforts with diverse standards and methodologies.
Last evening at the White House we enrolled a documentary
called freedom writers that recently won three Emmys.
After showing the film about young civil-rights pioneers beaten in prison in 1961,
the audience was given a chance to interview several.
When a student was asked what she
and others thought they would achieve when they started
out? Her response was they didn't know.
All they knew was it is the right thing to do.
Despite knowing what to expect,
facilitating this advance in ideas may be the greatest policy option.
Just as we need an infrastructure of roads and bridges,
we need an infrastructure of ideas. Thank you. [Applause]
Hello everybody, it's a pleasure to be here
and to participate in the first public plenary meeting.
It's gratifying to see an impressive group of leaders and experts both academic
and public from cultural institutions, technology companies
and people who care about education and community.
Thank you to the DPLA steering committee and the DPLA secretary
and a special thank you to our host.
Although we have been working on the DPLA concept for 1
year and people have been talking about it
and striving toward the digital library system,
today we are announcing the biggest effort yet to make
the stream library system a reality.
The digital resolution may render the library
insufficient but it has given us a digital tools to
create a new paradigm where people can go
and access knowledge online while preserving the physical
library as a center for community, education and empowerment.
The digital public Library of America helped us make this shift.
Participants at this meeting agreed to work together
toward the creation of an open network of comprehensive
online resources that would draw on the nation's heritage
from libraries, archives and museums to educate and empower future generations.
The meeting generated excitement and energy.
By January 2012 a blue ribbon steering committee was
formed and an active discussion was created.
In March the first meeting was held and in April,
DPLA met with funders and gained additional support.
In  me they met on ways we might work together.
They developed a working prototype. In June,
DPLA helped -- to support the legal work stream of the
DPLA initiative by developing solutions to copyright obstacles.
By July or 440 submissions were received
and in September a review panel selected the promising candidates for development.
Today we are seeing a grassroots progress for the
national library system to develop the prototype into content digitization efforts.
DPLA has accomplished a lot in 1 year.
You see the major leaders in this room today but a lot
remains to be done. We are a common format
and shared platform to facilitate discovery
and exposure of our digital heritage content.
Collections that exist like the library of Congress,
Stanford University, the Boston public Library and the Internet archive.
We're also talking about K-12 education
and letting students provide a topic.
Empowering people in community colleges.
Practical tasks like looking for employment,
renovating your house or looking at genealogy.
Shared code and interoperable data
and cooperative collection building with other nations in
Europe, Asia and Latin America.
Mobile apps that social media sites and books.
Pamphlets, newspapers, and much more.
The Digital Public Library of America is a big bold idea for the digital age
and the effort to support the existing library system
and assist knowledge to people everywhere.
The Sloan foundation has approved a two port five they
don't grant in support of the DPLA initiative over the next two years.
That Grant has been matched by the Arcadia foundation with another $2.5 million.
I would now call a Peter Baldwin.
I will be brief but I'm willing to bet there were a few
people in this room who have heard of the Arcadia fund until this moment.
We are not a big foundation,
but we share a lot of interest in common with them
and one of these is digitization.
We've been working on digitization for several years.
We have collaborated with Harvard and UCLA.
We have a project with the national Library of Israel.
We are cooperating with the Hill foundation.
We are trying to cooperate with the Internet archive.
All of these are a boutique digitization projects.
It is with pleasure we are able to stand here today
and be part of this move of the digitization project to a
new level into its Wal-Mart phase.
We are delighted to be able to punch above our weight in
present company. Thank you for letting us be part of this.
We think it is a project if it is accessible could change
things. Thank you. [Applause]